[Music]
football is about to start let's go we
are less than two weeks away from the
first preseason game the Hall of Fame
game the game that we wait all this time
and then as soon as it goes on the
starters are pulled after one series we
go cat demon how is everybody doing Inge
Brower you I'm good we were just in a
meeting talking about the Hall of Fame
Game Cup and like holy [ __ ] football is
back
it goes from man it's like so many
months I can't even think about football
and then all of a sudden oh my god it's
here two weeks it's funny cuz it's
always like fifty days till the start of
the season but really training camps are
back this week rookies are starting to
figure out their camps we're about to
start off holdout season we're also
about to start unfortunately the ACL
epidemic which I have not briefed you on
sure which is it's about to start
happening this week's gonna be really
rough that's my prediction hang on to
your ACLs out there it's these guys have
not cut in a long time and they go out
there and some coaches go full-speed and
it's is when it's gonna happen man yeah
just realized that this is actually a
pretty shitty week I'm sorry but in Burr
and I were on the road um coming up
later this episode we are gonna have an
interview with Case Keenum we met up
with we're gonna have a bunch of
interviews from that golf tournament we
went to but case talked about how do you
talk about battling with a rookie
quarterback without starting a
quarterback controversy I asked him if
he thought it was appropriate for me to
make him top five for the quarterback
grill rankings a little disappointed by
his answer but he you'll hear was very
appreciative of the ranking yeah and
when I brought it up to him he's like oh
yeah I saw that he goes how the hell did
you find that photo of my big green egg
and we will have another quarterback
rankings coming up after that interview
and some more whoa so stick around but
this week with training camp it really
feels like football is back oh yeah they
do a really good job of making just the
lead up to training camp feel a part of
the NFL season you like you can't escape
the concept that it is football
right now all the time yeah it just
feels like there's this excitement you
start to see those magazines Oh get
ready for your draft all that stuff's
happening to the point where a levy on
bail goes on a rant in which he says
does Beyonce sing as soon as she wake up
as soon as she wakes up does you know
like pretty much saying all of you are
questioning why I have other interests
than football but this is about the same
time last year that a Antonio Brown went
on the same rant but that's NFL fans in
the comments section do you start
podcasting as soon as you wake up yes
you do okay so that's a fiance it's not
happy about it I get like whoa and she's
like what's going on had a really cool
time hosting Travis Kelsey's charity 87
and running their foundation where they
gave a lot of money back to
disadvantaged kids in the Cleveland area
where he's from
they're their foundation raised $40,000
and then Travis and Jason each chipped
in 20 to match it so they raised $80,000
awesome that so thanks to Travis for
inviting me out there really cool event
to really get a lot of people cool crowd
yes it was all about the charity and we
got an episode of the show done oh yeah
and we can't tell you about it but it'll
be airing within a couple of months and
then we'll get to explain all the the
things that happen behind the scenes
that yeah this is the episode I'm trying
not to ruin it for you guys and I know
that a lot of you continue to ask
questions what is this going to be it's
just really doing dope [ __ ] with NFL
athletes yeah but I can't give it away
yet we were in Atlanta did some shoots
down there it's really hard for me not
to put things on social but it's all for
the good of the show a lot of you guys
are asking about fantasy updates I have
I'm trying to figure out where do we
want to do this on Yahoo ESPN there's
also a F I reached out to the fantasy
footballers
and they're doing something with the
sleeper app which I investigated it this
weekend it's a really cool app and they
said if you have a fan that wants to
kind of take the lead on this that's
what the fantasy footballers are doing
and I said well last year that was
meatloaf Henry so I'm gonna say this
audibly meatloaf Henry if you want to be
the king and
again I'm gonna give you until Wednesday
to respond if you're if you don't
respond that means you're not listening
to the podcast which means I cannot give
it to you which means I'm probably gonna
give it to the Saints fan wge - that was
at the live shows in Atlanta so just
being realistic I'm letting all the
homies all the 33% is there another
meatloaf out is there like a meatloaf
Jake nope
meatloaf Henry's the only one that
meatloaf Patrick I just want to know
their mate look meatloaf out there to
take care of okay what is the meatloaf
song well I was thinking like let me
sleep on it I'm asleep on it this is
what Lefko does at 7:00 a.m. so meatloaf
I'm putting it out there and if people
want to tweet it meatloaf go for it I
know it was a little bit stressful we
had 400 fantasy people but I want to get
the ball moving and I want you guys to
kind of I don't have any deals with the
sleeper app but I I'm just curious if
you guys want to check it out looks like
an easy way to run it but I think I'm
gonna give it to the super Saints fan if
meatloaf doesn't respond if he does I
love you meatloaf excited to have you
back so preseason starts a week from
Thursday which means we're about to get
into a hold out season mm-hmm and there
are two names that are coming alive
right now Zeke and Melvin Gordon right
what are the current updates of these
guys and the last thing that we're
hearing so with Zeke EAA's apparently
resolved has strengthened to the point
that plans apparently were being made to
travel out of the country in lieu of
showing up for part of the start of
training camp on Thursday which is a
pretty bold move and I also think it's
interesting with the Cowboys history of
guys going on vacation during important
times yeah I think of Tony Romo with
Jessica Simpson going on that trip but
the Cowboys are in a very precarious
situation their team is built around
Zeke you have a new offensive
coordinator that is likely building
everything off of play action killer
offensive line ready to go yeah you get
Travis Frederick back from his
mysterious illness so you got to think
that the running game is even going to
be better you also have to factor in
they just paid to Marcus
and they still have to pay DAC and they
still have to pay Amari Cooper but this
is also what the Dallas Cowboys have
done for the last decade which is
overpay certain stars and then push it
back further and further until the other
ones are ready to go
the other one is Melvin Gordon yes where
do we stand with him
the 2015 first-round pick Melvin Gordon
is scheduled to play under his five
point six oh five million 5th year
option this season and then he came out
and Sports Illustrated found a clip of
him looking at levy on bail and going I
totally get why he's doing it I'd do it
too which makes it very interesting that
Melvin and and I had hoped this would
happen last year with levy on bail hmm
we had been waiting for someone to set
the whole season to set a precedence of
fear to the other team like holy [ __ ]
this guy in his prime what is he 27 28
years old just decided to sit and
recover for the year rather than play
for under market and while I understand
all of the very smart NFL people that
say runningback values don't matter I
would argue that what these running
backs are trying to do is to create a
more fair market now the sports
analytics people would say the Chiefs
did not lose a step when Kareem Hunt
went out when Williams came in the
Steelers really did not lose that much
with James Conner coming in and I agree
in terms of drafting running backs it
probably makes sense to wait but what
I'm saying is for Zeke and for Gordon
they are not writing for roto world they
are not trying to look at the market and
see where they're devalued they're going
yes we've been devalued which means I
need to go to the farthest extent to get
any value right levy on Beltre he still
got 35 million guaranteed Zeke and
Melvin Gordon I believe are going to be
emboldened by what happened with levy on
bail and they will feel more confident
that they don't have to be the first
player to do what he did which is
completely sit out and also these are
two teams that believe they can make a
run at a Super Bowl Zeke the entire
fences being built around him Melvin
Gordon the Chargers are one of the
favorites to go and we saw last year
when it was just austin Eckler how
quickly he got worn down yeah it doesn't
matter to them if running backs aren't
worth that much they need to get paid
because running backs aren't worth that
much you know what I'm saying this is
their window to get that business direct
yeah and with levy on giving them the
confidence I think this is the year
where the team's might be a little
worried for it to happen
well you as you mentioned right we've
got the levy on bail precedence where
you're right the Steelers still had a
very good running attack with James
Connor I don't think necessarily
everyone knew that James Connor was
gonna be such a fantasy and on-field
stud that he was but even with that
precedence if you're the GM of the of
the Chargers right now you can't look at
that and say well that's always gonna be
true with every running back that sends
out I would still be terrified that I
would lose my job if we don't sign
Melvin Gordon and then our running
morning game goes to the crapper and I
can tell you that the Chiefs thought
that they could have done even better
against the Patriots if it was Kareem
Hunt not Williams and I can tell you
that there's a lot of Steelers that
thought yeah James Conner was good but
levy on bail would have even put us that
much over the edge and how much better
would they have been with levy on and
James Conner it's not a one or the other
situation if they had had a healthy levy
on bail and James Conner to come in on
third down and do some like you know
spicy trickery plays that could have
been you know is synergy right there in
the backfield I think that two things
can be true I think that statistically
there is not I think that there is no
position in football with a less
important drop-off than running back
from the 1 to the 2 but I can also
believe that there's no more important
position for a player to use his right
to hold out than it running back to get
paid like a number 1 yeah because I
looked at man Alfred Morris is getting
less than 7 million dollars in his
career that's crazy crazy I remember you
said that on a podcast the other day and
like I was I had to look it up so so as
all the think pieces come out about how
Melvin Gordon and Zeke should realize
that they they're not going to get paid
that much I'm just gonna say those two
things can exist in a fact in a vacuum
now there are other possibilities of
guys that could hold
out in the next few weeks one is
Jadeveon Clowney on the franchise tag
and I thought about this he was the
number one pick in the 2014 draft that
is the super draft that we're gonna look
at in about 10-15 years and go was that
as good as the 83 super draft this is
the draft that had Khalil Mack and Aaron
Donald knodel Beckham and D Ford and CJ
Mosley and Taylor LaJuan and Eric Ebron
like it's an incredible there's so many
guys I'm not even saying right and he
was first overall first overall and so
what I would say is when you're the
first overall pick the hype that you've
been hearing for so long yeah you
believe that you are better than Aaron
Donald and Kaleo Mac or at least just as
good and for everyone's saying that
Jadeveon Clowney he's being asked to do
different things then clown and he's
been hurt a little bit more but because
Mac and Donald and D Ford and Mosley
have all been paid huge amounts of money
and D Ford getting the huge contract he
did from the Niners like I think that
clowny is much better than D Ford if you
want to say he's not as good as Mac and
Donald I agree with you but Mosley
getting paid what he did it linebacker
if I'm Jadeveon Clowney and I'm seeing
everyone else in my draft class get paid
and my team is still the one that's
putting me on franchise tags I'm not
showing up to camp hmm I'm not there's
no reason to because you know what Mac
and Donald did last year held out they
were franchise tag and they held out and
they got a deal done cloudy's got to put
pressure on him I'm asked to Erin Donald
and Cleo Mac are two of the greatest
defensive players we've ever seen in our
lifetime yep Jadeveon Clowney I wouldn't
put him in the class of Loretto Baylor
Khalil Mac no no like best I've ever
seen but he's damn good yes and he makes
that Texans front really scary the
problem is is that if he holds out I'm
looking at what the Texans are doing
they are it seems like going to go
all-in on stealing Nick Caesarea from
your Patriots next year how dare you
it's what they're going to do like
trying to date my girlfriend behind my
back or something except they're doing
it right in front yeah and then ESPN's
covering the whole thing yet here's the
deal Nick Caesarea comes from the
Patriots you know what the Patriots
don't do Reese I and offensive linemen
mmm their first-round pick from five
years ago Malcolm Brown now on the
Saints right there big time defensive
lineman that everyone was obsessed with
Trey flowers they let him walk to the
Detroit Lions they did the Patriots
philosophy is will scout defensive
lineman and we're just gonna cycle them
in and out and we'll pay for the more
premium positions like cornerback which
they've done for Darrelle Revis and
Stephon Gilmore we're gonna find out our
quarterback and we're gonna invest in
offensive lineman they do not pay
defensive lineman so if I'm Jadeveon
Clowney I'm trying to get that deal done
before Caesarea comes Oh cuz he's gonna
come in with the Pats mentality he's
gonna say like look we won some Super
Bowls in New England by doing X Y & Z
and now I'm here in Texas I'm gonna try
to replicate that process sorry dude
avian you're gonna have to find
something how they do have Bill O'Brien
and they do have a number of guys in
that front office that were already
taken from the Patriots but now's the
time if I'm cloudy's agent to try and
make a move because there's no real GM
for the Texans so you guys want to act
like you have four people that are all
chipping in everybody knows what it's
like to work in an office where there's
not one person and everyone's chipping
in you push that pressure point so since
it's the players podcast Jadeveon
Clowney now's the time to hold out when
the front office is in disarray but more
pressure on him that's my my piece of
advice Chris Jones is another one Chris
Jones his problem is if he doesn't show
up the training camp they can make him a
restricted free agent next year this is
exactly what happened to Aaron Donald
Aaron Donald held out Chris Jones has
got to be sitting there going I was the
best and sometimes only good defensive
lineman that you've had for the last
three years we're clearly in our Super
Bowl window I know that you're about to
give them a homes upwards of maybe two
hundred million dollars yeah but you
just gave Frank Clark not like ninety to
a hundred I need to get paid
and so if I'm Christian like everybody
knows I'm all about holding out it's the
only leverage that you have like when
the CBA comes don't have a season don't
just hold out just as a collect as the
team's as the players just sit out yes
yeah I mean I know it's gonna suck but
what would you do during that season
from a podcast perspective yeah you
wouldn't have all of the players on
there available to get them so that's
what you do the no training camp perfect
let's do our own training call it the no
season tour and we just got a city to
city and just like people's living rooms
around yeah the other two that I'm very
much paying attention to one is Trent
Williams the reason Trent Williams is
interesting is he has been the left
tackle for Washington for a long time
and been the most consistent guy there
but if you remember before the mini
camps in like May and June the issue was
not money as much as it was he doesn't
treat doesn't trust the medical staff
that's such a big issue and that [ __ ]
comes up in any sport yes in basketball
a lot happened with the pelicans right
as soon as there's a definite with the
sixer Kawhi Leonard Kawhi Leonard Spurs
as soon as he as soon as there's a
distrust between these athletes what are
you gonna do like you can't get win that
trust back no you're in the training
room every day and you rely so deeply on
these guys yes and on the other side
when you hear about like the sun's
training staff and the in the 2000s when
like everyone was saying all of their
fixing amare Stoudemire's knee they're
amazing all they're keeping Steve Nash
alive this guy is amazing like when you
hear about that then all these free
agents want to come there it's such an
important I think part of the reason why
the Eagles move to their training camp
and people got upset they moved it to
their practice facility because it's the
Nova Care complex and it's the best
doctors are there and all of a sudden
their injuries went down all of a sudden
they saw it started signing more free
agents I've been thinking about this for
years because we talked about salary cap
stuff all the time like oh if you pay
Russell Wilson thirty five million
dollars a year you're losing your
competitive disadvantage because you
know you weren't able to pay all these
other guys but there's all these ways
that you can pay for value that's not
part of your salary cap and I always
thought that training staff was a
massive massive market correction that
could happen where if some of these NFL
teams just started like
spending 10x on what they normally spend
on a training staff it doesn't come off
your salary cap it doesn't hurt your
luxury tax or anything but it could
really improve your free agents and keep
guys healthy you bring this up I just
started a new book it's called atomic
habits by James clear it's about how to
break bad habits and start good ones and
I highly recommend that I'm only like an
hour into it but one thing he was
talking about was the British Cycling
Team and apparently for a hundred years
they were the laughingstock of the
cycling world they were so bad that
biking brands refused to let them ride
their bikes because they thought other
countries would drop the brands for
merely associating with them and is this
because they're very proper British
gentleman with like baskets on the front
of their bicycles heading down to the
the garden what the book is mainly a
passage I don't know what the book is
mainly about is every one every NFL team
says we want to win the Super Bowl
yeah just like everyone says I want to
get in good shape or I want to be good
financially but we think by just having
a goal that we're creating something but
we don't have a system to get there so
this new coach comes into the British
cycling team and he establishes a 1%
rule that we're gonna get 1% better in
everything that's not even involved with
cycling hmm we're gonna get better
clothing that's a little bit aerodynamic
we're gonna get better bikes that
improve it just a little bit we're gonna
get better training facilities we're
gonna improve our cyclists sleep we're
gonna improve the way that they breathe
like little things that had nothing to
do with actual performance I love this
that were all 1% improvements they then
went on a six-year tear where they were
the most dominant cycling team in the
history of science I love this stuff
they won like five of six Tour de
France's and they had never wanted Tour
de France before and that's why when we
talk about the Patriots and we talk
about them winning in the margins and we
talked about had like I watched the All
or Nothing with the Carolina Panthers
and the owner of the team as soon as the
season was over brought his front office
staff together and said if this practice
bubble is not done before the season we
an issue because he goes everyone told
me it didn't rain in Carolina and then
all throughout the season I'm having to
cancel practices if the practice bubble
is a 1% improvement for the Carolina
Panthers and you need to have an owner
like Robert Kraft or Dave pepper that's
willing to invest in the 1% when I watch
Kirk Cousins and there was a video in
his house and he stays in a in a
hyperbaric chamber is that gonna change
his entire season no but it's a 1%
improvement right that's what we hear
about LeBron Tom Brady the way that he
eats like all of those things are little
things a Phil ripped up the Phil rivers
like spaceship car Phillip Rivers
watching film on the way to practice
right 1% thing that's not gonna make you
the best quarterback ever but if it
gives you an extra two hours a day to
relax and watch film and you don't to
worry about it once you get a facility
and you're already caught up and you
de-stress if maybe that's an extra six
percent value who knows but it's
something the other thing I'll say about
this all started because of Trent
Williams and the medical staff is one
you talked about trust but also too when
you're an athlete and that's your whole
system and then you start questioning
whether the medical staff has your best
interest and you have an owner that is
notoriously like kind of cheap do you
begin like I bet you there's some
conspiracy theorists on that Washington
roster that are like they don't want to
pay me so now it goes not even just I
don't know if I can trust the staff is
this team out to get me I would think
about that as an athlete that's a
thousand percent and you think about
like you mentioned any other office
right other once you distrust a person
or a department or a boss then
everything that they do feeds into your
already existing paranoia and wonder if
it's malicious yeah and then you have to
remind yourself most people are not
malicious it's yes but it's hard the one
though that I have my eyes on the most
is Michael Thomas from the New Orleans
Saints and it's mainly because of a
quote that Sean Payton gave in support
of his player earlier in the offseason
that could come back to bite him said
Michael Thomas is the best wide receiver
in the NFL and he also said that we
expect to pay him Michael Thomas is due
this year 1.14 eight
their own dollars unreal I know that you
guys want to tell me that there's 53
guys on an NFL roster and that it's
different with salary caps and stuff
you're the same people that tell me that
Michael Thomas is the best wide receiver
in the NFL if Michael Thomas makes less
than 1.2 million dollars this year I am
shocked and I think that he's got to be
looking around and go and cámaras gonna
get a deal soon mm-hmm
Brees is getting over 30 right now like
you're gonna pay cam Jordan Michael
Thomas deserves a new contract and I I
don't talk about another team with a
questionable medical staff the Saints
and the pelicans share a medical staff
which is insane because they have the
same ownership group right just makes
you feel like there even if it the
numbers actually makes sense I don't
know anything about their training staff
but even if the numbers make sense I
would just still feel like they were
cheeping out on me and then once I feel
that way you can't get it out of my head
but if my coach went to the media and
said I'm the best wide receiver in the
NFL and that we're gonna get a contract
done well then that coach is not gonna
get the best wide receiver in the NFL
without a new contract injury okay and
to everyone that says he needs to be
there he's got to work on the
connections Aaron Donald held out last
year defensive MVP Khalil Mack held out
last year
runner-up defensive MVP Tom Brady didn't
show up the training camp won the Super
Bowl
Fletcher Cox when he held out won the
Super Bowl I do not need my players in
training camp because the Michael
Thomas's of the world have been working
out all offseason right you see them on
social media they're going hard they
have their own personal trainers or own
dieticians this is not the 70s where
they're gonna come in 15 pounds
overweight smoke and Marlboros it's not
that anymore I think that's what people
picture that it's like you're either at
camp going hard and learning the
playbook and you know working out or
you're at home watching Netflix eating
snacks right one or the other but it's
like no I'm pretty sure that he's got
his own facilities and his own personal
trainers and like I'm sure he Michael
Thomas knows drew Brees his playbook if
anyone the world knows it and I'm gonna
give my left go PR that I had for Odell
Beckham last year which
is Michael Thomas you need to put out
one workout video a week where you're
absolutely dominating because what's
gonna happen is just to insta Tait
Institute everyone a left go PR if you
don't know if you put a video of you
cutting with a Drake song in the
background websites like bleacher report
and the check down and all this stuff
they're gonna put out Michael Thomas
grind and even though he's not a camp
and then the pressure goes back on the
team because all you need to do is show
the fans that you are working out and
then you're good oh yeah because to all
the fans that say you should be happy
with what you're getting I say shut your
mouth you're not invited to the
conversation too bad talking so you hit
me up last week and said hey the BR
gridiron folks have asked you to do your
division winners right and I responded
with crap I haven't actually like done
my research yet so these are the
division winners as of July 22nd we are
going to do when our new co-hosts are
officially announced a full season
preview about third week fourth week of
August the week before the start of the
NFL season where I'll do my official
division winners wild-card teams Super
Bowl winners MVP Offensive Player of the
Year coach of the year all that stuff
but my division winners got a lot of
arguments online good and it's mainly
because you said hey the other people
take chalk the other yeah I mean it's
hard not to go chalk in certain ways but
as you know every year you look at the
playoffs from last year than the
playoffs from this year and every year
there's some replacement right as 12
teams make the playoffs it's rare that
like seven stay in the play the average
is 6.4 there are 12 teams that make the
playoffs and they've done the average
and each year about 6.4 teams are in the
playoffs the next year
and every year we go into which means
half of the NFL playoffs
don't come back right and then every
time I buy a [ __ ] magazine they pick
chalk yeah and then they go this is
crazy
how did Washington get in the playoffs
because it happens every year because
then it's an evenly and there's always
one or two teams like okay Aaron
Rogers mrs. eight weeks of the season
you can't predict that before this is
right
a healthy Aaron Rodgers is almost surely
gonna make the playoffs a healthy Drew
Brees is almost surely gonna make the
playoffs you can't predict those but
then there's also just a couple of teams
that come out of quote-unquote nowhere
and sometimes that's not nowhere
sometimes like they were seven and nine
last year and now since that team last
year yes the Chiefs and the Colts the
Chiefs many people thought with a with
the first year Patrick mahomes maybe six
wins that defense look stupid and then
they came out there and they're the
number one seed in the playoffs they
were from week one they were incredible
from week one Patrick mahomes did not
stumble at anything gate at all so the
division winners that I am picking let's
start with the NFC East last year the
division winner was the Cowboys right
I'm going with the popular pick in the
Eagles right now I went through the
rosters it was close between the Cowboys
and the Eagles the reason I chose the
Eagles over the Cowboys was I do not
expect the dak Amari Cooper love
connection to be as strong I don't
believe in Jason Witten coming back
after a year off like that's your main
tight end like I got out loud you know
what I mean
but I do look at the Cowboys and I think
they're really dangerous because Travis
Frederick is a huge addition back to
that old line it provides so much
structure that o-line but look I had the
Cowboys winning the East last year I'm
going back to the Eagles this year I
think the NFC East has just always
seemed it always seems like there's
never a clear clear favorite preseason I
always feel like all four of those teams
are gonna beat the crap out of each
other
they're all gonna like go one and one
against each other it always feels like
you know and that I'm not science
even though what if Daniel Jones comes
in in week 1 and throws for 400 yards
and would you change your tune after
week 1 no no ok because we checked week
1 is my least favorite week in the NFL
season because it's always the Ryan
Fitzpatrick throws for 450 yards and
five touchdowns and everybody the Bucks
oh my god
yeah or like last year a week one I
think the Bucks beat the Saints right
you know what I mean or you're right
that's what you just said right well the
other one would be the one I always
mention is that Monday Night Football
game when the Niners beat the Vikings
and then they lost their next 15 games
yeah like they went one in 15 but on
that Monday night football Carlos Hyde
does a spin move gets memed out of this
world so I hate week one and I've seen
north is the one that I got the most
hate from Chicago Bears fans they're the
team that won the north last year got
very upset with me I went with the
Packers I looked at all the teams I have
already said that I believe the Bears
are gonna regress I just I I think that
they had a really really good team last
year defenses regress everyone's gonna
go yeah but the defense I go look two
years ago Jacksonville had one of the
ten greatest defenses of all time and
then last year it was garbage
the Bears I just I think it's gonna come
back to earth I just I know that true
Biscay could take another step forward I
just don't think it's gonna be good the
one team that I think could [ __ ] me up
as a Vikings yeah I think the Vikings
are a very solid team I forgot they did
that they drafted Garrett Bradbury to
solidify the center position but I still
don't think their defensive line is deep
enough and when I looked at the Packers
defense and I saw all their new weapons
with za'darius Smith and Preston Smith
and their savage in the secondary and
Adrian aimost and then I thought about
this offense with Matt Lafleur and I'm
not saying that I trusted Matt Lafleur
but I trusted Matt Lafleur and Aaron
Rodgers
because I think that they're gonna have
a healthy relationship and I'm I'm all
that on the Packers this year I like you
I mean my feeling I love been on Aaron
Rodgers right it's you feel just safer
knowing that all things being equal
Aaron Rodgers is a better quarterback
than anyone else in that division yes
and very fair right when when you're
making division picks that is a that is
as good of a criterion as anything and I
love the fact that there will not be the
questions early mid season of is
McCarthy on the hot seat hmm it's a new
beginning and it's clearly Aaron's team
I know Lafleur is the coach but Rodgers
is like the same age as him and I think
it removes a lot of that like I've
always thought that Aaron Rodgers looked
at McCarthy and is like I [ __ ] carried
you for a decade like I've carried you
yeah everyone around the like he did an
interview where I heard him talking
about saying like I
would watch other offenses like Kyle
Shannon's ago man I'm a little bit
jealous well now you have a guy that
comes from the Shanahan offense here's
your chance buddy let's do it yeah NFC
South this is the other team
I don't you did not hear how much the
Saints fans hated me last year because I
was saying things about Drew Brees and I
was very insulting but I'm picking the
Falcons I think the Falcons to win it
last year am I crazy for this like are
you going with the Saints look what the
Falcons were in the Super Bowl a couple
years ago Matt Ryan's just as good as
ever
according to your friend me no kind of
underrated QB in the NFL now the only
article that got picked up yeah I mean
Julio Jones Devonta Freeman like that
offense can put up 35 a game would you
be surprised at all if they put up 35 a
game and you know go 12 and 4 I would
not be surprised at all I think the
Saints are gonna win the division again
because that offense is unstoppable and
they have one of the best home crowds in
the world but yeah that again Falcons
Panthers wouldn't shock me either if at
113 days whole division is crazy I look
at the Panthers and I think oh they got
Gerald McCoy there front seven is like
jacked right now but then I watch the
all-or-nothing I forgot they were like
one of the worst defense is the NFL last
year the Panthers and I don't know where
Cam Newton's health is but I love
Christian McCaffrey I look at the Bucs
and I go what if Bruce Arians taps into
Jameis Winston hmm what if these last
five years everyone's been going Jameis
play more calm Jameis play more
respectful but really he needed someone
like Bruce Arians to come in and go
Jameis be crazy like what oh yeah what
if it was like more judo where it was
like go with the craziness and go no
we're gonna try and beat people 45 to 40
instead of Jameis don't throw the ball
like on your back foot like let's be
crazy this feels like like some coach
that like talked to Mike Tyson early in
his boxing career and is like don't try
to like yourself just go out there and
be Mike Tyson and that's when he went on
that crazy run but the reason I picked
the Falcons was I look at their team and
Devonta Freeman is back healthy I think
they have the best wide receiving core
one through three in the NFL I know 1 &
2 is probably the Browns but 1 through 3
of Julio Ridley Ridley and Mohamed Sanu
the other thing that I love is in
addition to the defense being healthy
and Neil being back and Jones being back
and they actually give a contract to
greeny Jarrett is they drafted two
offensive linemen in the first round hmm
and they're getting dirt cutter back and
so I just think that I just look at the
Falcons and I I think that they they
always play the Saints really really
well and I don't know I just I think the
Saints are gonna regress I just I know I
shouldn't bet against Sean Payton I say
this [ __ ] every year no you're making
picks this is this is the point of
making picks because if you're right and
you pick worth I thought it was their
year last year and I think that window
is gonna close and I think it's gonna
suck I don't I still don't think they
have a real number to wide receiver I
think that Jarret cooks gonna be great
and Camaros gonna be great but they lose
Mark Ingram but it's also that defense
like I know that defense was making
plays last year but I still don't trust
Ennis Alan and I don't know I know that
that feeling of like the kind of aging
quarterback he had that one year it's
all shaping up to be the drew Brees
beautiful capper he wasn't Superbowl and
retires but it also could be more like a
Tim Duncan 2013 where everyone thought
that was their year and then they came
back and won it in 2014 with an even
better team
I should have been against Sean Payton
you just yeah it's an infrastructure but
you know what like it's all about odds
it's all about picking a little against
chalk like why would you pick chalk
that's no [ __ ] chalk yeah so I went
crazy in the NFC wow this I love
everyone's picking Rams
some people go in Seahawks I went Niners
love it I love it why not
I went Niners here because when you
realize that they were one of the top
offensive and defensive efficiencies for
the last two years under Kyle Shanahan
and the recorder but excuse me have been
Nick Mullens and CJ Beathard thank you I
look at that team and I I love the
running back core they got like four
running backs
I like their offensive line what I saw
it on McGlynn last year I loved Kittel I
loved some of their young wide receivers
like debo Samuel and Marquis go but now
it doesn't have to be the primary guy
and I look at that defense and I go they
got D Ford and Nick Bosa
and DeForest Buckner is still there I
just feel like they're gonna break out
and I look at the Rams and I disagree
with Mena I do think the Rams take a
step back because I'm just telling you
right now I know they have Aaron Donald
but this [ __ ] defense Pro is not
something that I'm excited about at all
they are so shallow this is their
starting D line other than Aaron Donald
Dante Fowler who I do not trust I have
not seen consistency
Michael brokers who is solid tan Zell
smart okay Trayvon Young Greg Gaines
Sebastian Joseph de John Meyers Franklin
Sampson a Buchan who had one good game
ageing Clay Matthews like who the [ __ ] I
don't know any of these dudes I don't
and I look at their quarterbacks and I
do think that their secondary is gonna
be good
their secondaries gonna have to make up
for a lot of it but I just think their
front seven Aaron Donald's amazing but
when you lose Suh and you lose some of
those other guys like I just think it's
that much easier to double-team him talk
about a team that went all-in for the
year 20 years yes they were like here's
some one-year contracts cuz we're gonna
win it right F and now yes and then they
didn't do you believe in that losing the
Super Bowl curse I I think that it has
to sit in you a little bit
yeah but especially cuz you put up three
points yeah that does bite look I
believe in the Patriots curse more than
I believe in the Super Bowl curse which
is after you play the Patriots Bill
Belichick gives the game plan on how to
stop your offense oh yeah because he is
the master of figuring out what is your
number one and taking it away and I know
they didn't have Cooper cup and I know
that Todd Gurley was banged up I'm not
the biggest believer in Jared Goff I
love Sean McVeigh he'll definitely
adjust I just think the Rams take a step
back and I looked at the Seahawks I went
to Russell Wilson's Pete Carroll they'll
probably get a wild card there might be
two wild cards from that division I
haven't had to do that yet but I'm going
Niners I'm rolling the dice you never
bet against Russell Wilson making the
playoffs cuz he's six out of seven years
as a starter right I mean that's amazing
six out of seven years as a starter to
make the playoffs oh you don't bet
against that but yeah one of those teams
gonna have to win why not and I'll go
I'll go quickly through the AFC I was
always going to take the Patriots I was
always going to take the
deshaun Watson the rest of it often just
gets hurt too much and I don't trust
Bill O'Brien here I went with chargers
over Chiefs this was before Tyriq Hill
was not suspended I was expecting Tyriq
Hill to be suspended for four to six
weeks sure he was not suspended at all
do you change the pick it off um I like
to me that's a Chargers Chiefs coin flip
I would probably go Chiefs there now
it'll come out come down to like one
Sunday game that they play in December
that decides it all I do worry with my
Chargers pick that they're one of those
last year was their window but when you
when I looked and I realized they added
Nasir added Lee in their secondary and
they added that first-round pick at a
Notre Dame on their D line I kind of
looked at them and went they addressed
the two issues that I had for them and
but you know what if they lose Melvin
Gordon for the year that changes that
picked - the guy was Jerry Tillery so
that one I probably I'm already saying I
got it wrong but I rolled the dice on
the Browns in the north I know they're
the popular pick and I probably should
have gone against the public there and I
if I didn't pick the Browns I was gonna
pick the Steelers mm-hmm even with all
of their losses
I just Ben Roethlisberger and Mike
Tomlin get it done a lot and I think
that Ben is gonna be so motivated to
prove he's more than brown and Bell I
looked at the Ravens all of their losses
on defense with CJ Moseley and those
guys scared me a lot and I don't know
what's gonna happen Lamar Jackson but
that division is up for grabs Lamar had
his you know his run that every captured
the nation for whatever was seven weeks
that row can he do that again for an
entire season there's a little more game
tape on him you know teams have prepared
for his speed a little bit more you
can't quite gameplan for it but you can
come close it'll be interesting to see
if he can if he can replicate that the
interesting nugget is the rise of
first-round quarterbacks from year one
to year two
it's almost unanimously more successful
sure so that means you have to factor in
the Browns the Ravens the Jets the bills
and Who am I missing
because there was five quarterbacks
taking Lynch Rosen I'm not bad not okay
runs the fifth quarter but I look at the
Jets and the bills and I love the bills
this year yeah and I love the
this year and I'm really curious if this
is the first year where the Patriots
with losing Gronk and losing some of
those guys in the d-line I am never
calling for the Patriots in I picked
them the wind division I think this is
gonna be the hardest year for the
Patriots in years I think the Jets and
the bills are both gonna be fighting for
a wild-card spot
I mean honestly like I'm a Patriots fan
and the last 20 years have been so
amazing I'm not trying to like gloat or
anything it's been an incredible run and
it's it would be kind of fun if like all
the teams were like nine and six heading
into week 17 it'll be fun
but I think this is the year I think
this is the year where the AFC East gets
really murky yeah and I'm tempted to
take the under on the Patriots for the
first time I don't think they've gone
under their win total in like eight
years in a row which is insane for the
over/under that's crazy is that true I
have it's um okay yeah cuz I chart at
all because like a lot had to have been
a year without adding websites delete
what their predictions were oh [ __ ]
annoying so you have to just so I try
and yeah I'm a degenerate all right
let's uh let's go out to Lake Tahoe
where we had a conversation with Case
Keenum who which you'll see is still a
very down-to-earth guy and we're very
impressed with his journey so here's our
convo with Case Keenum
I am honored I am blessed and I am
cherishing this moment to be with the
number for grilling quarterback in the
NFL today congratulations thank you yeah
there you go I put out the rankings I
had you for add you behind Brees
Stafford and I had to put you behind
rivers cuz I assumed somebody with ten
kids has to be incredible in the grill
yeah I don't know how much they go out
to eat I feel like he's got a he's got
to have I went back I saw the beak I'm
not crazy right you're really good on
the grill I saw the big green end yeah
that rack yeah that was a family deal so
I'm not gonna not mess up your rankings
by saying it was a there was a group
effort right I'm in town I was
brother-in-law's like we were all in
that together this is really thrown it
was just it was impressive how far back
in the archives you went in the social
media to find that
yeah I saw a post from like Andy Dalton
like seven years ago of him using big
green egg like it's scary because people
forget how far back their instagrams go
oh I know you know oh yeah our kids are
gonna find so much so much crap on us
yeah dad was a weird Washington yeah how
is it so far
how you feeling yeah it's really good I
I'm enjoying you know joining the East
Coast never been over there I mean this
is obviously another new team what team
members is for you now it's got to be at
least seven or eight I mean we made the
move with the Rams so if you can't st.
Louis in LA as different teams
yeah we've moved like eight times in
eight years this is amazing for your
post career because then you could do
speaking engagements in like eight
different cities yeah talk about those
different teams yeah for sure I think
some may be more loved than others but
yeah that's how it goes I don't know I
don't think any fanbase would ever have
anything bad to say because you've taken
whatever the situation is and try to
make the best out of them yeah I mean
that's what we all got to do right I
mean you know and there's a lot of other
things I'm obviously we're judged very
very you know harshly on how we do on
the field but there's so many cool
things we got to do off the field and
people we got to meet and charities we
got to be involved with and and just the
communities everywhere I mean from
Houston to st. Louis LA Denver Minnesota
and now Washington's been pretty good
Washington traded for you right yep
what's it like to be traded for the NFL
you know I I like the way you you they
traded for four yeah and what has ever
traded me yeah [ __ ] I got traded for
yes so yeah because Washington needed
you yeah exactly what got you that's how
I feel
I was undrafted so I think I've been
traded for draft picks like three times
so that's what I think I was like I'm
drafted now yeah yeah that means right
yeah you actually we drafted like 70
when you go to a new city is it now like
you know the flow of how this all goes
like do you were the first time you went
somewhere and now like how different is
that experience yeah I'm from Texas born
and born raised went to college in Texas
so we thought we'd be in Texas forever
so on with Houston the Texans right out
of college team you were Houston to your
core oh yeah we uh we still got a lot of
h-town show
in our blood but I think moving to st.
Louis the first time was really shocking
just kind of mind-blowing it's hard on
me and my wife but we're all pros at it
now I remember your hard knocks where
you guys would sit there and go over the
playbook huh and now you've probably
played not only for like seven teams
eight teams but probably for like 11
different coordinators to like is it
really what they say it's like learning
a new language like is it really like
that like going like rosetta stone and
learning for sure yeah yeah now there
are offenses that are that are more
similar you know say like like Spanish
to Portuguese gotcha cannot speak either
so what's cheek is Chi grit and similar
to any others that you follow it's
somewhere to a Kubiak just a West Coast
style so you know if you call that you
know the Americas you know yeah
Portuguese Spanish and then you know
there's other things that are like my
Chinese Mandarin you know like some
other offenses that I've learned that's
just totally different and then you have
the digit system over here I think you
like the Patriots it's like not even a
language exactly yeah excitedly yeah
it's morphed into its own deal so that's
that's the thing there's all these
branches of like West Coast and branches
of digits and I want to ask you like a
is a weird media question okay if I
asked you do you want to be the starter
no [ __ ] [ __ ] you want to be the
starter who doesn't want to be the star
right right right but if you say that
and then you have a rookie all of a
sudden we got ourselves like a little
like a competition thing going home how
do you navigate being at someone's
teammate but also wanting to be the guy
and not starting a meet you know what I
mean like you're kind of in an
unwinnable situation with that stuff ah
I've got a pretty good pretty good
handle I've done it a lot of time I mean
you know I was in LA when they drafted
Jared yeah and you know so I know how it
goes and we all want to play and I think
as long as we're all I mean you know
adults and we know that we're all
competing for the same job and that's
gonna make us all better
like I want Dwayne to play awesome you
know I want Colt to be his best and I
want me to be at my best and I want my
best to be better than their best that's
the competition part of it I think they
would say the same thing if they were
here it's interesting because I've heard
from some quarterbacks that the head guy
sometimes wants someone that's not going
to challenge them because they want to
feel a little bit more confident yeah
and and I'm going no dude you think
Google's hiring like crappy number two
guys oh you want the best guys to
compete with you yeah that's everything
I mean that's every job you know that's
radio show host you know I mean pay
there's somebody that wants to be in
your seat and you've worked your tail to
get there and you're gonna continue to
do that
to stay there and you know hopefully
keep going so I appreciate that but I
was talking at this you can actually
help me I was asking Kyle Rudolph
because I had Kirk Cousins last in the
grill rankings he's had a few pictures
that have scared me he had the picture
with tinfoil in a mixer with some meat I
don't like hot dogs and hamburgers or
just like simple it was steaks with like
a tin foil underneath which why would
you ever do that but also very
unseasoned can you confirm or deny Kirk
Cousins being a good I can't I don't
know
can't can't say I bet he does I like
rocks and he puts them to count the
months as Kirk is very funny to me I
feel like he's like a 50 year old dad in
like a 29 year old guys I don't know I
I'm not gonna comment on that Benjamin
Button is what Kirk Cousins is actually
70 years old so where are we right now
as you enter like this offseason like
you're going for the spot you have to be
right but then also you're not gonna
[ __ ] up my Eagles with Washington this
week was it that gap and you're gonna be
starting well I mean no you're gonna be
starting I'm just gonna tell them right
now the key I'll bet I'll bet you $100
that you start we've won why would I why
would I bet you that that's why I'm
making the bet I'm not gonna that one of
the best guys the NFL Case Keenum but on
an incredible journey super happy for
you and a top-five grill I had the
quarterback position
thanks man all right so you could hear
on that that case keenum killed me that
he did that big green egg and it was his
cousins and all that stuff I really
thought it was him on the grilling tip I
don't know if you guys saw this Kirk
Cousins put out a video in which he
bought
nearly 22,000 dollars worth of grills to
give to his offensive lineman what a
nice gift in the video he went out there
to use his grill and it was out of
propane like they talked about him being
grilled online so much and I'm like it's
okay Curt just come and grill with me
bro
I will help fix this but a lot of you
guys have been asking what is the new
quarterback list to be honest in Burr
and I've been on the road for two weeks
it's been a lot of [ __ ] work and I
was like let me just take two weeks off
the quarterback list from this week he's
already gotten one list approved easy
ultra best dancing quarterback I love it
Eli is not gonna be last mainly because
of the commercial where he listed owed
lifted Odell over his head hmm and he
also had some funny dad dancing in the
locker room Baker is likely going to be
first what we've seen out of Baker thus
far has been phenomenal dance moves
I am also I have not thought about this
at all we also you know I'm the criteria
guy when it comes to these lists are
someone's gonna be very low but are we
talking about dancing at a wedding are
we talking about learning steps with the
rock handing very close to you and it's
gonna be that moment at a wedding when a
circle for the worst and this guy goes
in in burr is not a fan of dance circles
at weddings this is my that is not a hot
take but it is one of my strongest takes
I feel fervently that when a circle
forms at a wedding everyone should just
walk away from the dance floor and just
make the people who form that circle
feel really bad I hate it I am literally
purposely inviting people that will be
good in dance circles so that my wedding
has a good dance circle because I will
agree with you on this when a dance
circle forms and everyone's looking
around like you're gonna get in you're
gonna get in and no one gets in I feel
like that's when a lot of people
mentally check out of a wedding Oh
could a dance floor I was at a wedding
my fiance's fiance's friend's wedding
and I do round the dance floor and did a
backflip and the place lost it and the
party went up a notch for the next 45
minutes and and so I guess that's what
this is is who is the one that's gonna
go on the dance floor and do move
that takes a wedding up a notch since
wedding dance circle QB challenge I love
that wedding dance circle QB challenge I
I would encourage the 33% out there to
send us any sort of videos you've seen
yeah the last few years because I'm sure
there's like some video of Matthew
Stafford doing some crazy worm in the
middle of the floor oh I saw when's
doing like a dance at his wedding and I
was like you are low bro like Joe Flacco
no way no but sometimes you don't know
right again right like Tom Brady
chugging like me people think that I'm a
bad dancer and I'm a great dancer
sure and the thing is by the way when I
say that think about the wedding circle
people think that I hate dancing I love
dancing at weddings I just don't want
anyone looking at me or judging me or
thinking that there's some sort of
contest that's going on I just want to
dance
alright so that'll be coming out later
this week three whoa big offseasons and
then wrangling it to some fan questions
why don't you go through the first one
the first two I selected for you are
both Patriot stories but I want you to
read it to get the full yes oh and by
the way mark if we're doing a little big
offseason that means it's time for
[Music]
Bingle all right so we go to New England
Braxton Barrios which is such a wide
receiver the Patriots would have white
wide receiver flowing blonde locks
rookies report training camp July 21st
with veterans following them July 24th
but some players are already trickling
into Gillette Stadium a bit early one of
them is second-year receiver Braxton
Barrios 8 days early
it's so perfect that's so whoa I love
the fact that a guy showed up more than
a week ahead of time because there's no
it's not even like a day it's not even
like like five minutes early is on time
this [ __ ] showed up eight days
earlier but think about it Edelman's on
the pu p Gronk's not there there's a lot
of fighting right now for the position
people are just slotting in to kill
Harry and Braxton Barrios is saying I'll
be here eight days early I'm curious
though if Bella checks there eight days
early do you ever like show up for like
a job interview twenty minutes early I'm
so Walker but you just you don't want to
go up to the building yet so you just
kind of circle around the block once or
twice and then you make it seem like you
got to tie your shoe for a long amount
of time what do you do for a flip in
days you play play PlayStation I don't
know you just look out the window and
like you wait for someone to show up so
that you like I'm working out I'm
working out I'm working out right all
right back to New England Maurice Harris
studies the playbook with his wife yes
Harris has made a strong impression on
the Patriots coaching staff with
football acumen showing early that he
understands the challenging concepts and
part of that as a result of studying the
PlayBook with Kayla who comes from a
football family he was along with her
Richard Rodgers enters his eighth season
as a Panthers secondary coach in 2019
yeahokay Lee's brother Richard the
second which sounds like a Shakespeare
play is a six year veteran who has been
with the Packers and eagles who javante
Adams told us as Loki when the best
basketball players the NFL Richard
Rodgers he's also the guy that caught
all those Aaron Rodgers Hail Mary oh I'm
well aware but what I love about this is
if you remember from the Hard Knocks
with the Rams when it was Jeff Fisher
Case Keenum would study the playbook
with his wife and I love that dynamic
but the fact that she's with a football
family and she's gonna be able to go
it's an inside trap Maurice like I love
and I never know how these stories get
out like I never know how these whoa big
offseasons
like make their way to these reporters
like who asked like who are you studying
the playbook with well it's cuz you you
know you were a local beat reporter you
know all over the place like you hear
nuggets you overhear stuff you don't
know exactly know where it comes from
but you're talking to somebody they pass
it on to someone else then someone says
hey did you do you hear about
such-and-such you follow up on it you
get enough credible sources that you
think it's worth putting out there you
put out 30 of them and only one of them
that's worth being low alright and now
let's get to the best one the summer
fangio continues everybody my favorite
old Italian coach and we talked about
this on the road a bit but Vic Fangio
has officially banned music from
training camp yes okay quote it makes it
hard to talk to your guys I don't see
the benefit of having music out there I
was an assistant coach and I don't want
to drum out the noise to talk to my
players he also said they don't play
music at games which upset a lot of
people yeah but then that he actually
said when I was responding to people in
this next quote when it goes to the
point where we need to stimulate crowd
noise in practice which we will
assimilate crowd noise in practice which
we will do it will be noise the coach
said it won't be music it will be noise
that's what it is in the game noise by
definition sounds annoying music sounds
it sounds nice so we have to deal with
that noise let's deal with new ways
because everybody responded to if they
don't play music and NFL games with like
well like how you don't you need to
simulate the game the reason I agree
with Vic Fangio so much here is in
training camp you're putting in your
base [ __ ] you're putting in the most
elementary and important parts of your
offense and your defense and no one
knows how important it is to install a
new system than Vic Fangio so if music
is just there because if you watch all
or nothing you saw Cam Newton running
around and putting on music and stuff
it's to lighten the mood but Vic Fangio
is sitting there with a lot of very
young team the Broncos are super super
young and he's trying to teach them a
new defense he's just old school man and
I [ __ ] love it and when it comes time
to pump in noise they'll do that but I
all of Vic Fangio zwo are whoa
to me because he's super well and it's I
love all of his decision I don't mind it
at all I've never been someone that can
get work done while listening to music
on headphones yes I'm putting on a
podcast or anything like great point I
like putting on a podcast and going for
a walk but if I actually have like even
something as simple as like filling out
an expense report if someone's if
there's music in my ears I'm gonna be if
30% slower doing that I promise you and
yeah they can say that it's about
communicate I don't know man I agree
with Vic Fangio to a tee but this is
what happens when Sean McVeigh says if
Sean McVeigh would have said we're not
doing music at practice people would
have said genius move but because Vic
Fangio is like in his 60s he's
old-school and archaic right you know
yeah and it's if if Sean McVeigh would
have said like I think Vic Fangio also
came out about like cellphones giving
them like cellphone breaks and it's like
always trying to connect with the young
people but if Sean McVeigh gave cell
phone breaks it's he's connecting with
young people so I think there's a little
ageism when it comes to Vic Fangio where
we're assuming that everything is
archaic when really here is an assistant
coach who has been the NFL for like two
decades and has been known as one of the
best coaches in a league that's never
got an opportunity to be a head coach
and when he gets his first opportunity
apparently he went in in that interview
and pulled no punches and was like they
suck they suck we got to fix this he's
gonna do it his way Vic Fangio has been
watching coach after coach after coach
right I have never seen a coordinator
survive more head coach firings than Vic
Fangio he survived John Fox he survived
like multiple head coaches in San
Francisco he is watched so many people
try and fail that if there's one guy
that probably knows the right levers to
pull it's probably Vic Fangio and
ultimately if they go to learn more from
bad bosses than good boss that is true
if they go out there and you know they
win 11 games this year everyone goes wow
that no music thing what a genius move
well if they go six and ten people go
man he should have kept it light in the
locker room it literally has nothing to
do with their performance on the field
until we see their record we can just
speculate that's what that book that I'm
reading about like talks about where
it's like we reverse engineer our
success and put it on one thing I'll
complain
collection of a million one things it's
not like yeah yeah that's actually a
very funny thing every time the Broncos
win be like thank God they didn't play
music in training camp I might do that
I feel like this whenever I'm watching
Netflix you watch like Breaking Bad on
Netflix and Netflix goes like oh you
watch Breaking Bad here's a bunch of
documentaries about meth and I'm like no
that's not the reason why I watch
Breaking Bad
like they have attacked it was the fact
that it was a really good television
show is why I watch Breaking Bad all
right so we got three fan questions all
from Twitter where do you want to start
smooth TV three oohs yeah what current
athlete what do you want to smoke a
daddy cigar with any sport any support
okay um so NBA I'm gonna do jr. Smith
I just his stories who was he gonna
bring in the room who know you would
wake up the next morning with the tattoo
a cool tattoo Junior's face on my back
but I I try to think about what the NFL
was guys I'm not saying that they do
smart smart disclaimer we don't know not
saying that they do because I do not
know but these are guys that I think
would either have a fun crew B would
have a lot of fun conversations and see
I just do one to see I think I did so I
see people that I think would be funny
on a daddy cigar a quarterback I'm
picking Cam Newton I would like to try
on his clothes at his house like I feel
like that would be a really fun thing to
do
he's vegan he wouldn't have the best
snacks but I I fell in love with Cam
Newton after watching all or nothing
what a great leader what a hard-nosed
dude I watched the whole series
yesterday like one through eight like
ice put my entire Sunday watching all or
nothing nice and Cam Newton is the man
yeah running back on picking Alvin
Kamara I just feel like he's he he's a
really cool dude he's got the nose ring
and stuff I feel like he'd be very
relaxed he's New Orleans so I think like
the music would be fun I just think
would be good we'd be in a studio his
uncle represents the me goes wide
receiver picking juju cuz juju is gonna
be like you want to go into a bounce
Castle I'm like yes
two defensive linemen I'm picking Von
Miller
I just think Vaughn like again trying on
hats putting on glasses I've hung out
with him before so I know he's like a
really good time and he's all these guys
are very friendly I'm not trying to do
it with like a Melvin Ingram who like if
I say something wrong is gonna punch me
in the chest as a friend but he doesn't
know his own strength so I'm not gonna
appreciate it and then Jalen Ramsey
because he might be one of those guys
that's gonna talk a little bit of crap I
don't mind that at all yeah yeah you
want to it's it's all about accentuating
the things that you want them to be
chatting about yes exactly he's the sort
of guy where Jalen Ramsey cuz we all
know that he can talk [ __ ] with the best
of them but maybe on a daddy cigar he
has this sort of like more mellow Zen
approach talking [ __ ] about people might
be great it's more of like a loving
thing it's like look Josh Allen I didn't
mean to talk crap about you I think
you're a great guy man he's also one of
those guys with a very descriptive face
that you might be like Nathan Peterman
and he might be like yeah and it just
freezes you because it was such a funny
moment alright enough daddy cigar talk
Brian
underscore Aguilar if you could pick one
player from each of the last three
drafts 17 18 and 19 to have a guaranteed
Hall of Fame career who would they be
alright so I looked up the team's 2017
the honorable mentions
I had miles Garrett and Jamal Adams
miles Garrett feels like a pretty
slam-dunk choice of this both are
starting off with a lot of Pro Bowls a
lot of recognition Jamal I was getting a
lot of all pros I'm going with mahomes
yeah when you've won an MVP already and
you're 23 you're half of the way there
yeah because I find that the guys that
when MVP are more than more than not
going in the Hall of Fame
so mahomes is that guy and you know you
have like Dashon watts and stuff but I
think if I had to pick one guarantee I'm
picking my home's 2018 is gonna be a
really good draft to I don't know if
it's as good as that 2014 draft that we
talked about but Durand James was up
there another guy that was an all-pro
already Baker Mayfield I think say Quan
Barclay is gonna be a hall-of-famer but
we don't know how long those careers
last we could see Baker making the Hall
of Fame but you could also see Baker not
being in the league when he's 32 who
knows but the one that I'm picking is
Quinton Nelson mmm-hmm quit Nelson to me
already all-pro all
like when I see people talk about
quitting Nelson they're already saying a
hall-of-fame levelguard like they're
already saying like they're not saying
that about their calling sake one
generational yeah they're calling Baker
the franchise but with quit Nelson
they're literally comparing on people
like Anthony munos like they were
already seeing that and then for 2019
I'm not answering that question who the
hell knows like all of these rookies
like I don't know okay I'm not answering
that question let's revisit this
question after preseason I'll tell you
whose colleges in a month okay great
you'll know because because preseason
always tells everything yeah one more
question from the fans yes 11 Jordan
Cole asks who's your favorite player
all-time from each of the Eagles
division rivals which is interesting
because you usually hate these guys but
as it goes on you start to you know if
there's a rivalry that you like mm-hmm
the Giants I've always liked Amani
Toomer like I've always liked a much
because he killed the Eagles so that's
why I didn't pick him yeah but I think
my favorite giant is either Brandon
Jacobs but I went with Jeremy Shockey
mm-hmm Jeremy Shockey had such a good
rivalry with the Eagles and I was always
jealous that he was on the Giants he was
just a badass that like kick people's
asses and I liked him a lot
Washington I always had a thing for
Steven Davis the running back that had
like 1,400 yards one year I liked him I
did like Pierre Garcon for like a long
time and I always liked Lavernia Scholz
those were the Washington Redskins that
I liked and then for the Cowboys
I get joy I wrote down to Marcus where
but who was the running back that like
ruined so hard that he like his career
lasted like like a few years damn it he
went to Minnesota agent Robert Smith um
Marion Barber the third oh yeah sure
arian barber the third was an absolute
baller he had was so reckless like this
is gonna be my example of like NFL
players and how awful their confidence
because Marion barber gave everything to
that team and in his career as I look it
up now it says four million dollars
there's if he made four million dollars
in his career that's the most
embarrassing thing I've ever heard but
it's possible but I would pick Marion
Barber all right so you're a Patriots
fan who are your Dolphins bills Jets
yeah for the Jets Jericho Khatri love
Jericho just hands for days
just let incredible highlights sacrifice
his body yet great great highlights he
was on that 15 and 1 Panthers team 2 and
no one remembers that that's true he had
huge catches in the Superbowl also you
can't underweight it for receivers great
name oh my god right like Jericho
Cotchery just he had so many R's in his
first name all I needed was one of them
to go to the second one to become
Jericho crotch free you know what never
happens I've been for the Dolphins
Cameron wake stud just great story and
just monster Cameron Wake is on our all
whoa big offseason team yes he's never
had a beer and he's he's never had a
beer and he only eats healthy because
that's how much he cares about his body
that my dream is to do an episode of the
show where we give Cameron wake his
first beer that's great that's my dream
that's delightful and then for the bills
I'm not gonna overthink this one Thurman
Thomas just growing up you know when the
Patriots stunk my whole childhood like
you just you you'd watch the games that
were on TV you know we didn't have
whatever like all the internet channels
to get pirated games whatever you're
watching a lot of bills games Thurman
Thomas like what an absolute monster he
was just felt untaek Allah belad times I
know it wasn't a pretty respect and I
have not watched enough Thurman Thomas
in my life had the speed to come around
the corner but also we just like Emmett
Smith it up right down the middle and
like you kind of like the NFC guys were
Emmitt Smith guys and the AFC guys were
Thurman Thomas guys for a while my
husband had a motive Ben Bruce Smith
that's a good one
it just it was the haircut and the fact
that he was in little giants and crushed
the football mhm that always stuck me
yeah as like how incredible he was so I
always loved Bruce Smith and Jim Kelly's
the [ __ ] boss yeah but you have a
favorite Patriot of all time lawyer
Milloy and tile are up there yeah sure I
would go though with
who was the big nose tackle Wilfork no
Ted Oh Ted Johnson no Ted [ __ ] he was a
nose tackled a number of teams
I guess Ted Johnson yeah Ted Johnson was
a linebacker yeah now I'm running
through my my mental rolodex Who am I
missing I'm missing big names this is so
embarrassing no no he was a nose tackle
let's see if I can find this out from
Google nose tackle Louisville University
Patriots Raiders I also loved Richard
Seymour I love Reggie head Washington oh
sure
Ted Washington was one of those guys
that when I would play Madden would be
like a 97 defensive tackle and I just
wanted him in the middle and like I have
a soft spot for defensive tackles
because I think that they define whether
you win or lose and they never make it
to the Hall of Fame because they never
have tackles and they never have sacks
but they got double-teamed and
triple-teamed on every play and
everybody else exactly 100 person so I I
have a soft spot for like the Ted
Washington's of the world that's the
Vince Wilfork thing cuz Wilfork was on
the Patriots for like 15 straight years
and it was like every year everyone
agreed he was the best defensive player
but every year he had like thirty eight
tackles you know because it was like why
isn't this guy get tackles oh right
because he's in the backfield getting
blocked by three guys on every planets
how I feel about Jadeveon Clowney cuz
like not to wrap it up with that but
like I look at you TV and clowny and
everyone's still talking about JJ Watt
and clowny was the one getting
double-teamed last year you know so it's
that has to weigh into it homies y'all
are the [ __ ] again meatloaf Henry good
luck and responding of two days I feel
good about this coming up a little bit
later we're gonna cash in on the dance
rankings we'll have more interviews from
Tahoe I have no idea who we're gonna
play next and the show is coming along
so hit me up for in burr oh you waiting
for me to say something yes
tomatoes on sandwiches are overpowering
in bed ha ha ha ha
we'll talk to you guys later
[Music]